notre histoire c'est celle d'un grand
parti de droite qui a donné à la france
ses institutions avec et autour du
général de gaulle moi je suis fier fier
d'être d'une famille politique qui a
fait voter 2 grande loi sur le handicap
celle de 75 et celle de 2005 fier d'être
d'une famille politique qui a tant fait
pour le droit des femmes
liv et j'ai avec simone veil et jacques
chirac c'est nous et personne d'autre
fier d'être dans une famille politique
qui a toujours depuis 1945 défendu la
politique familiale que françois
hollande puis emmanuel macron ont
détricoté si les français avaient voulu
que nous disparaissions ne serions plus
là
il n'imagine pas en réalité au plus
profond d'eux-mêmes que la vie politique
française puisse se structurer sans un
grand mouvement de droite capable
d'assurer l'alternance un grand parti de
gouvernement qui puisse demain reprendre
en main le destin de notre pays
le temps de la récolte viendra est ce un
paysan et mouldi car nous avons en nous
cette cohérence idéologique rebâtir
donner un nouveau français à l'échelle
nationale l'envi de nous écouter l'
envie de nous respecter de nous suivre
il faut travailler notre projet avec
conviction avec humilité avec sang froid
c'est ce travail qui est en cours et
c'est autour de ce travail que nous
devons rester mobilisés
un travail qui s'appuie sur un socle de
valeurs la liberté l'autorité le progrès
est sur un héritage profond dans
l'histoire de notre pays
[Musique]